it's a banger actually great well we're
rapping over can't touch this i mean it
definitely will be awful right
there's no way this isn't gonna be bad
we'll pick out the suggestions from the
chat there's so many suggestions guys
right i'm gonna take
the inventor of adobe pdf dying getting
rick rolled riding on a werewolf anal
bleaching and the tactics of a
successful game of tag
thank you so much for suggesting those
everyone um let's drop this beat
i love it right start with birth and you
end with death if you invent that pdf
portable document format and you're in
the coffin on your back
inventor you know me i'm the guy from
adobe
i died this week everybody they cried
they were like oh no he lies probably
from germany or america if you're
the church oh yeah i'm telling you got a
distance socially like the queen when
prince philip died oh she wasn't keen
she was there on her own not sat on the
throne
got a pdf right in my home if you want
to have a little smile don't confuse it
with a pdf
file pedophile joke that's such a pun
when i'm on internet we have some fun
getting rip roll cause i'm clicking the
link and i thought it was gonna be
something i think that i read no
it's just a guy rick astley and he's
side to side when he's moving saying
chris you're in luck cause i'm never
never gonna give you up oh got the
golfing class i want a werewolf when i'm
galloping past i wanna ride on the back
can i come so soon
in the afternoon now not a full moon
hate the vampire hate van helsing if i'm
on a werewolf yeah i can't sing all the
songs that i know about silver bullets
i'm on that werewolf so i pull it the
reins i mean
cause i'm beside him right on his back
when i'm riding oh
can i snide with a comment if i got the
werewolf fast like a comet like dasher
and dancer the reindeer
got a bit of poo on the ring here gotta
clean that so you know why i'm reaching
down there get that anal bleaching ah
making it shine like the moon
why cause when our moon wanna show that
bum and it's naked everybody's like we
can't take this
so bright with a ring and the anus pull
it out all the time i'm shameless
when i get that bleaching it's painless
i don't even know what the aim is
all right oh gotta break it down guys
it's kind of hard to wrap over the
breakdown because he does just go whoa
you can't touch this you can't touch
this
you can't touch this can't touch this
because i'm getting mad that's the
tactic for the gamertag if you get
touched then you're it if you get
touched then your [ __ ] i don't mean if
you touch the child underage then you're
not [ __ ]
don't get enraged go to a therapist i'm
talking out here are the tactics i'm
talking about
oh be quiet never make a sound when
you're running around that playground
and i found you
take your it and i say is it tigger's
attack anyway doesn't matter if you
scream if you howl at the werewolf
you can switch the vowel there we go
that's a little rap ran out of breath
like the guy with the pdf
oh yes